léonard on peut entrer ni
pas de réponse allons-y quand même
tiens ça m'allait ferney
il était en train de faire une petite
sieste on c'est dommage avec un temps si
merveilleux où tu as raison gelli nous
allons le réveiller allez paraissent de
réveille toi allez allez allez debout
debout c'est pas le moment de dormir ce
qui se passe ici pas moyen d'être
tranquille pensez vous quand vous voulez
vous mais nous venons de réveiller il
fait un temps magnifique et je ne dors
pas enfin je suis en train de lire les
mémoires de casimir
comment tu t'es tu lis à l'intérieur de
deux pas mal fermée donc fait les
honneurs du doigt rien y voir du tout
comme vous
[Musique]
je m'éclaire à mettre cette lampe de
poche voilà je suis équipé mois mais
dis-moi léonard je ne savais pas casimir
avait écrit ses mémoires c'est moi qui
lui ai demandé de le faire je veux
savoir tout ce qui s'est passé sur cette
île avant mon arrivée par mais vous faut
c'est une très bonne idée et c'est
intéressant oui à mon grand étonnement
quitté passionnant j'en ai le souffle
coupé
mais ce qu'il peut écrire petit ce
casimir devrait pattes de mouche je suis
obligé de me servir de cette loupe dans
les eaux que l'organisation et où en
es-tu à l'histoire de pierrot et
colombine
deux énergumènes qui ont rendu deux fois
visite à gaza du mois les amarres
pourquoi appelle-t-on pierrot et
colombine des énergumènes parce qu'ils
ne font rien comme tout le monde et il
ça me plaît beaucoup dommage qu'il n'y
ait pas de photons d'eux edward avoir de
drôles de têtes un argument peut être
savoir à quoi ressemble pierrot et
colombine oui oui alors oui et bien ne
bouge pas dit s'il julie et moi nous
allons les chercher
je vais enfin voir des gens ordinaires
[Musique]
où
oui oui
oh mais dieu très jolie comme ça julie
en colombine comme toujours d'ailleurs
et toi tu es très réussie en pillant les
spots je crois que j'en arrive bien sûr
pays va sûrement beaucoup nous admirer
ne le faisons pas tout à fait raison
trop vite
monsieur les amarres monsieur le renard
monsieur long nationale à prendre mais
tient de vous tous les deux cette jeune
personne est ravissante se nomme
colombie mais c'est génial s'appelle
pierrot
piron et colombine dit ce monsieur c'est
bien pas mal un petit mois m maître
renard alors pierrot et colombine
s'invite lui saint lô attendez attendez
maître renard vous allez nous voir en
entier
c'est pourtant vrai il ne suffit pas de
mettre son nez à la fenêtre pour
m'étonner monsieur du jeune fille cela
trois fois par jour et hop nous voilà en
entier maître renard comment
trouvez-vous nos costumes
il ya un effort mais ça ne brille pas
assez je trouve
ça brille pas assez bon
maître renard les amis de casimir et en
nos amis nous pourrions peut-être une ou
tutoyer je m'attendais à une manière
d'être plus féerique enfin si tu veux
mon dieu comment vas-tu léonard wap
outils comme ça c'est tout ce qu'on nous
avait raconté oh non non non tu as
remarqué comme il fait beau aujourd'hui
bien sûr enfin je ne suis pas
complètement idiot si c'est uniquement
pour me parler de la pub du bon temps
comme vous êtes venus vous pouvez en
partie
françois il faut absolument trouver
quelque chose d'original tout à fait
d'accord avec toi je lis mais quoi nous
n'avons pas eu le temps de répéter un
semblant de numéros
jamais ici les tournées de jallet vous
proposer un petit massage itunes c'est
le jeu d'ea siens en voici pour colombie
merci l'anah et pouvoir s'il pour
pierrot merci léonard là à la dernière
c'est pour moi je la pose là maintenant
vous allez faire exactement comment
d'accord
frottez le don donatien comme ça oui
avec la main comme ça maintenant
passez-vous la main comme moi autour des
yeux autour des 6 levier c'est amusant
quand je savoure frotter un peu la
voilà et vous vous passer la main au
bout du nez comme ça au bout du nez pour
vous aimez vous refroidit un peu la main
et encore il va tout sur la joue je la
joue
et maintenant voilà conviés vous vous
regardez dans ce miroir oui d'accord
maintenant vous n'êtes plus comme tout
le monde et vous commencé à m'intéresser
attendez attendez je joue vous trouve
très beau et est très sympathique vous
savez ah bon mais alors léonard pourquoi
ne pas nous l'avoir dit plus tôt ça nous
aurait fait plaisir mais aussi
parce que parce que je suis timide
léonard
[Musique]
en minimes